this was no normal pre-election speech
scheduled Leighton with a sense of
urgency it wasn't about policy good
evening everyone it was about the
stability of the nation my fellow
Americans
were facing a defining moment
an inflection point
make no mistake
democracy is in the ballot for all of us
his party May well be trailing in the
polls her drubbing next week is possible
and so of course he's looking for votes
but the president sought to get beyond
that this is not about me
it's about all of us it was a warning
about what he sees is the fraying fabric
of American society
struggle for decency and dignity a
struggle for prosperity and progress
a struggle for the very soul of America
itself
every day since he lost the 2020
election Donald Trump has cried foul
claiming continually without any
evidence that he won
you know American democracy under attack
because
the defeated former president of the
United States refused to accept the
results of the 2020 election
every recount confirmed the results
yet polls suggest that up to 70 percent
of Republican voters believe President
Trump
Mr Biden drew a line between what he
called the big lie and the hammer attack
last week on the house speaker's husband
the assailant ended up using a hammer to
smash Paul's skull
we don't settle our differences in
America with a right a mob
or a bullet or a hammer
there are up to 300 Republican election
deniers on the ballot next week Trump
allies like Arizona's carry Lake if they
win they will judge the validity of the
next presidential election an
intervention like this is extremely
controversial saying in such Stark terms
that only his party stands for democracy
is he essentially telling voters that
the nation's democracy has already been
lost
and just days away from the elections
into such a tense environment it's high
risk indeed Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington
[Applause]